welcome back to the david pakman show i
am of course not david pakman i think
i've said that at the beginning of every
segment so far so there's no need for me
to explain i'm benjamin dixon sitting in
for David let's talk about the battle
for mosel this is a this has been a
long-planned offensive by a combination
of international forces I think it's
interesting that the forces that have
combined to fight back against Isis in
Mosul have very different interests and
their interests actually are competing
interest yet they have combined to fight
off Isis and there's the so-called
Islamic states control over mosel and
actually Pat let's pull up that graph
that shows you all the different forces
that are involved in this this offensive
you see the pinkish territory is
controlled by ISIL the blue offensive
that's coming from the government and
its affiliates this is the Iraqi
government and its affiliates including
the United States we have some soldiers
that are there in a support role you
have the Kurds the Peshmerga from
Kurdistan they are coming from the north
and the northeast coming down into Mosul
and then you have Shia and Sunni
militias coming from the southwest as
well as the Northeast I mean all of
these forces have competing interests
for instance the Peshmerga i believe the
picture that's on our screen now our is
a battalion of Peshmerga fighters their
interests they are actually a
semi-autonomous state that whose
interests are to get sovereignty and to
and to have self-determination for their
people that directly conflicts with the
Iraqi government's goal the Iraqi
government because the Kurdistan Region
actually intersects with mosel so the
Peshmerga they're fighting on behalf of
their interests on behalf of their
sovereignty and their desire for
sovereignty and they're aligned with the
Iraqi government who's fighting for
their sovereignty to push out Isis so in
general the offensive appears
to be going well it may last a full week
if not several weeks but the big
question is how does this region survive
after the absence of Isis after Isis has
been pushed out of the city you have all
of these competing forces who have
different interests and could very well
devolve into their own type of conflict
I guess this goes to the statement of
the enemy of my enemy is my friend in
this scenario because each of these
groups rightfully so could be competing
enemies but they have a greater threat
in the form of Isis if you recall about
two years ago Isis swept down literally
in a storm from Syria in the north and
took the city of Mosul mazule and
there's a picture of all Baghdadi who is
speaking in front of a mosque giving his
orders to all Muslim people across the
world this is actually in the city of
missoula this really is a defining
moment in the plight of Isis Isis their
legitimacy is based on whether or not
they can actually build this caliphate
whether or not they can expand the reach
of their region and have the legitimate
use of force in those regions and
control and have sovereignty over there
Caliphate and if they lose Mosul which
is one of the last major cities
underneath their control you recall to
crit was liberty' was liberated in
Tikrit rather was liberated in April
2015 Ramadi was liberated from Isis in
December 2015 Fallujah was liberated in
june of this year so major city after
major city in Iraq has been and in the
region has been liberated from the
control of Isis so this completely
obliterates the narrative that Isis is
some type of Destin Caliphate to control
the region and Pat once you get rid of
that narrative you really undermine
their most powerful propagandizing tool
which is join us because we are the
the servants of God to expand this
caliphate but you aren't really this
expanding a Caliphate if you keep losing
ground so this is one of the reasons
that there's so much weight being put on
this particular fight in Mosul yeah if
the Allied Iraqi forces are able to to
recapture mosel and they're ahead of
schedule now this is only day two it
would be a very strategic and symbolic
victory they have far more troops I
think 90,000 compared to Isis's five to
seven thousand and it looks like the
last major city in Iraq will be
recaptured by the Iraqi government yeah
and actually we have a graph from CNN
that gives you an outline of the forces
that are fighting there's is
approximately 5,000 troops Isis fighters
rather fighting in this conflict there's
about 98,000 total forces fighting
against Isis included in that are u.s.
troops now this report from CNN is
actually a little low actually very low
in terms of US troops the last report a
600 new troops went to participate in
this fight to bring the total to about
5,000 u.s. troops who are participating
in a consultative role there there as a
support role but you can see Isis is
completely outnumbered here's the
problem with the father battle on the
mosel there's still 1.3 million
civilians left in the city and Isis is
already using them as human shields this
is urban warfare so it's house-to-house
door-to-door room to room and this is a
very difficult situation when you have
so many people who can be used as human
shields so this is not a given the
victory is not a given but with the
numbers on the side of the opposition is
very likely that Isis will be pushed out
of this major city once and for all
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fee
these and our audience can get a free 30
day trial at gamefly offer.com / TDPS
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free 30
day trial for the david pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s